you have the canelo stuff on i do jesus
christ that was this is probably the
best thing did you see what happened to
the guy's [ __ ] face yeah we have it
here too did you kill the plant's face
he got [ __ ] up man no and it's just a
translation mistake because
you know they're pushing each other and
then
canelo thought he was talking [ __ ] about
his mom but caleb plant said
[ __ ] oh canelo thought he was
talking [ __ ] about his mom oh of course
there's a translation error there right
so that's why canelo can all sock them
in the [ __ ] face
all right so this is ariel that was a
show on his instagram you sign with
showtime on showtime pay-per-view he
goes a [ __ ] that's why canelo
pushes him pushes him here now watch
look how fast this is so fast you don't
look like much boom that left hook
blasted his eye open simply that fast
and then look at this oh [ __ ] that's the
damage
[ __ ] i couldn't even see the punch gets
in the way of training actually yeah
he'll be all right there fights in
november so it should be yeah
caleb is a bad [ __ ] yeah tough
fight oh it's kind of
kale plant it's a tough fight for canelo
though too
i think the only thing is if he can keep
if he if caleb didn't keep him at bay
with that with his punches he punches
hard man he's a very good boxer tough
fight yeah
and then people are saying that he never
landed us the first shot so caleb posted
this that he did him hit him with a
slack otherwise i want to see where
canelo did though
if canelo had it hit him
he did
his cheek right here yeah right but but
was it but it was like
definitely but
be interesting
i'm ver i'm very much looking forward to
this you want to bet on it
go for it brian go for it brian what
would what would be the uh whatever you
want stipulations go forward what do you
mean
i think it goes did
i'll bet you canelo finishes him
you think so oh yeah yeah i'll bet you
that's it have you watched kale plant
fight yes i have watched that thing
ain't going a distance somebody's
getting knocked down excellent fighter
yep bet on it
bigger bet on it hits his heart brian
you got this
i love taking your mic you don't know
what you're talking about
kale plant is
[Laughter]
really good yep names three opponents he
spot mike lee
um
and i don't know the other two but i
watched that yeah yeah but he looks very
good he he's undefeated
yeah bet on it yeah i might have to bet
on it they'll do it now what would you
want to bet what would you want to bet
i'll bet you
gets a it doesn't go to decision canelo
wins by tk or kale
how many how many rounds is the fight
would be 12 round five that's boxing
yeah that's championship round
they change those things up never you
know fight under 12.
yes
it's boxing yeah
yep
i'll take that back bet your gran
oh boy oh
oh
that caleb wins
no that that occurs
i think if anybody's gonna beat canelo
it's caleb plant he's hard and he's a
very [ __ ] good boxer how much do you
think that messes with his head though
this thing
that he landed
the biggest thing in my opinion is can
he keep
canelo at distance yeah because it's you
know but he's just as big and he's not
afraid of him that's another part of it
yeah he's just ain't afraid man
and trains he's nobody's afraid at that
level i think guys but guys are kind of
like nobody that fights canelo like some
of the guys can always fight like
nobody's terrible i mean he did he did
then again he's canal's beating
everybody man including the who's the
russian guy the russian kit yeah who's
huge finished him
huge finished him it's unbelievable body
shop
he's a monster he's a monster
he's you know he's fought triple g twice
yeah i had triple h he lost one yeah for
sure last one yeah but i mean still it's
a good fight and i like kayla plant oh
yeah i just like your money better i
think
if caleb plant
can't beat him now he'll never beat him
let's put it that way kayla plans
fighting at the that the prime at the
top of his game how old is it so now
oh look
is exciting
right now
if it's the right matchup it is yeah
you know you're right 29 29 yeah he's a
b
[ __ ] beast he's from not i think
perhaps in knoxville mm-hmm
31.